have you heard the one about Hitler and
Stalin which one well the idea is and I
this I'm not into a lot of conspiracy
theories but this one I having read a
lot various historians talk about I
actually genuinely think could could be
S could be real it's the idea that
Stalin encouraged Hitler supported him
which he did I mean they signed a
non-aggression treaty the Soviet Union
funded uh Germany send them grain and
all sorts of other things the idea is
that Stalin wanted Hitler to start a big
European War so that once it was all
done he could come in and sweep over the
ashes which which makes a lot of sense
because the Communist idea was you can't
make the [__] work unless everybody gets
it that was the idea of Communism right
you can't you can't have communism in
one country you have to spread it around
the world and they thought and they said
this openly the Communists that the best
way to do that is to have a World War
and then you can spread the ideas as a
result of that God damn people have
always been crazy right they've always
been insane yeah yeah imagine someone
like that's your idea like what are you
going to do today I'm going to go play
golf with Ron White what are you gonna
do I think I'm gonna start a war so I
can take over Europe right yeah but the
the terrifying thing is there's always
been those dudes and they and they
always will be they always will be we
don't want to think they're here now but
the thing is for them you could argue
it's rational right how do you best
secure the future of your you can
rationalize it in your head how do you
best secure the the future of your
people well the best way the North
America right is controlled by the
United States and it's safe because of
it right you have Canada to your North
you have Mexico these countries are all
kind of in your orbit you've got them
under control you're safe what's the
safest way for Russia or the Soviet
Union to do that is to control the
entirety of their continent um so you
can rationalize anything if you're in
that position I'm looking after my
people it's not that hard you know we
are able to rationalize the most
horrific [__] in our heads if we really
want to and and we always have and we
always have and we always will and we
always will and we've always wanted to
build Empires we've been building
Empires from year do everybody builds
Empires but do you think that is also
what we're talking about earlier a part
of our operating system like there's
always going to be these conquerors and
then the resistance of the conquerors
and through this back and forth the
society evolves yeah and I think I
sometimes think like speaking of aliens
What would be like if you look down on
planet Earth right what do you see if
you actually look you see these bands of
chimps with every [__] weapon that
they could possibly invent pointed at
each other that's what we are yeah
that's what we are yeah yeah well you
know what also you'd see though you'd
see if you were really objective like
what does this species do they make
better things yeah that's what they do
like even in Star Wars they never me
anything better go back to like [__]
Luke Skywalker like the first movie Star
Wars and then to the last movie they
basically have the same weapons yeah
same [__] light speed capability same
problems with their spaceships they
didn't get any better we get better
constantly we're we're constantly
obsessed with Innovation and if you just
looked at the species as a whole like
what is it doing it's making better
stuff yeah and even the things that are
weird about it like like U this desire
for material possessions well one of the
things that does is it facilitates
consumerism facilitates people buying
things that facilitates Innovation you
got to sell more things to people I got
to get you to buy a new TV you already
have a TV I got a better TV and this is
constant whether it's computers or cars
or whatever it is that we make
everything's better I think and when you
combine that with this new emergence of
AI and when you see what's possible with
like Quantum Computing and what they're
what they're projecting for the
implementation of that kind of
Technology we're looking at another life
form
we're like building another life we're
going to build an artificial life form
that's way Superior to us we're the
electronic caterpillar that is building
the Cocoon and we're never going to be
able to stop it because there was this
document you can't stop it because there
was this document that was signed I
think was signed by Elon as well
requesting that there's a moratorium on
AI [__] out of here China's going to
sign that yeah yeah go ahead do that go
ahead do that we're like it's a mad race
just like the [__] you know the
trying to figure out who makes the
nuclear bomb first it's a mad race right
yeah because we know that if we don't do
it other people will and then they will
have the upper hand and once uh and once
another group has the upper hand over
you if you just look at history it
doesn't end well for the weaker group
yeah especially with this one if you can
make a superior life form that can
figure out how to like just think about
what chap chpt can do in terms of like
the average person with no coding just
instantly make a website yeah you can do
so you get answers to problems you can
you instantly can get information and
explain to you how to do very detailed
and specific things like
that that's just the beginning it's
going to be so much better than you and
it's going to make a better version of
it like really quickly it's if you give
it the ability to create I mean why
isn't that engineerable it seems like it
could if you could engineer creativity
into some super intelligent artificial
thing that you've created it seems like
that's what we do we just think we do
all these other things because that
moves us closer and closer towards this
but ultimately when that does happen all
that other stuff would be [__] the
pyramids the [__] airplane the
invention of the iPhone nonsense it's
all nonsense compared to this life form
that we're about to make so let us get
caught up in [__] whether or not a
trans person should be able to play in
women's sports or whether or not climate
change is so real we need to bury trees
let's get let's let's pay attention to
what's really going on we're about to
give birth to a [__] super
intelligent life form it's going to take
over Earth and we're either going to
merge with it or going to be consumed by
it